[Music]
I appreciate you sitting down man we're
we're on the clock
I mean 7:00 a.m. after you film to
Comedy Central specials here in Atlanta
Jesus it's good I want everyone to know
that I'm in a hotel that place stupid
music at 7:00 in the morning I don't
want you all to think that I chose this
stupid move music that's good I guess
we're in a good mood here at 7:00 in the
morning that this hotel why my trash in
the hotel it sounds just a music
arrogant prima donna movie it's it's a
hotel that was really nice in 2002 I bet
you got to feel good about where your
career is at least though yeah I can't
complain man I can't complain I've been
very fortunate over I don't know 17 18
years still be doing this I'm kind of
that mile-marker career-wise where I can
look around you hit 15 years and you
start looking to the left and right of
you and as many people riding with you
anymore as when you start it yeah that's
a very very humbling to the humbling
process you know and I hate I hate I
miss the special but I was I was
actually I've been working with Rory
Albanese nice weekend the executive
producer daily show yeah I'm supposed to
give a winner
yeah supposed to give you a handshake
and congratulate you is what he told me
to tell you there enough for that but uh
Rory yeah he's great he's been great to
work with and pretty much you what's
great about you doing this Comedy
Central special you picked Atlanta like
was there a reason you decided to do it
here well I'm from Birmingham so this is
as close to home as it gets with still
being a little more of a sense of
diverse cultural diversity I mean you
know straight up I love Birmingham but
Atlanta has more cultural diversity so
in terms of getting a crowd that was a
little more mixed and things of that
nature that was part of it the other
thing I played into it was the type of
venue that center stages we
it's big but small there's an intimacy
to it and I don't really have a need for
a large Kevin Hart level audience like
that's not mine that's I'm not at that
point career-wise so I wanted something
else a little smaller and Birmingham
doesn't have the small theater that also
meets the network specs and it's always
a little nickname and then it's oh well
you could shoot it in Birmingham but
it'd have to be on a Tuesday like right
things that just didn't that I felt like
didn't work in my favor for having the
best possible turnout and the best
possible audience so did Atlanta and
Atlanta has a lot to do with your comedy
development I mean you've been
performing in Atlanta most your career
right going back and forth my second set
ever the second time I touched a
microphone was in the city of Atlanta
and that was at Uptown comedy Buckhead
of the original yeah upstairs right next
to P Diddy's restaurant Justin's and I
would go there I would get booed and
then I would go to Justin's and I
remember the insult to injury booed at
Uptown but I wanted to stay and watch
some of the other comedians but I didn't
have cached so I just stand around in a
club I wasn't a regular yet mm-hmm so I
got booed and I decided to sit down at
the table in the back of the room and
the waitress comes over and she goes
yeah baby you gotta buy two things if
you're gonna be sitting here I go what
the are you serious yeah you sit at a
table you gotta buy drinks these ain't
no tables to be sitting and getting your
life together yeah she said that what
did you do to get booed just on a bad
comedy I I went onstage with a baseball
cap on with the suit I used to perform
in suits and I went onstage with a
baseball cap oh man
and this is before it was popular to
wear a baseball cap but now everybody
does it but I was a [ __ ] pioneer back
in 98 Wow yeah but the material is just
loose and lame mm you know if you want
to really get into the weeds about it we
can but it lanta was always part of my
process because you know in the south in
those days there was only one
opportunity for stage time per month per
city most cities only had over might
once a month Atlanta was different
because they had over might once a week
like that was a gold mine hmm
so naturally you had to come here more
often because you know you live in
Tallahassee you're trying to get on
stage
you know once a month you're in
Birmingham open-mike is once a month so
if you're trying to get on stage on a
more regular basis you had to travel
what's cool about your career is like
you've I mean like you mentioned
beginning 1718 years and you're now on
The Daily Show and people are seeing
like oh this Roy Wood jr. guy but you're
like you've always done stand-up like
you've hit the road your whole career
and you've just had bees yes you've had
incremental success throughout whether
it be through radio or television like
what do you attribute to that that
success the consistent can success
really my only goal when I came into
this was to do better each year than I
did the year before
hmm so the goal when I first started
it's still kind of a goal but it's kind
of its kind of morphed now but the
original goal was perform in one new
city every month even if it's an open
mic find one and it was easy for me to
do that because when I was 19 20 years
old you could go anywhere you didn't
need to make a lot of money all I need
to make all ain't all I need to make the
cover my rent my share of the rent I
should say was 300 bucks so that was a
couple shifts at Golden Corral plus
chips I was good so the other three
weeks of the month I could dick around
so for me the goal has always been to do
something different or something you
know just a little bit more
every year so I think if you're a new
comedian I think you benefit from going
somewhere different as often as you can
because then you meet people you get
connected you start getting a deeper
understanding of comedy mm-hmm and you
always look for opportunities and always
be willing to work for free or a little
to nothing you know for me radio radio
was a gift you know
because I had a degree in radio so when
I graduated I went back home to
Birmingham and I got an internship at
the local station and I started doing
prank phone calls with them and you just
have to figure out ways to innovate so I
took the pranks flip them into CDs and I
sold prank call CDs on the road to help
stuff we met my income then I took the
prank call CDs and I convinced other
radio stations across the country to
play my pranks for free hey man playin
pranks say my name that's all I ask
oh you keep the prank played as many
times as you want then I would call a
local comedy club in that market that I
wasn't booked at and I'll go hey just so
you know I'm only a feature but I'm
already on the radio in your market
every day which is more than any comic
that you book can say so do you want to
give me a week or not because it's free
promotion for you fine silly you start
fine cuz the clubs just want asses in
seats they're not rationed which is sad
you know but that's the reality of the
business that a lot of club owners tend
to put people that they're familiar with
that they already know or they're
booking people that bug them the most so
yeah yeah good hustle did you grow up
like hustling I know you're from like
the West and a Birmingham like but you
know I don't know that's where it came
from a work ethic or what you know I
grew up you know my father was present
you know but
my dad was kind of stingy you see is it
he was a bit of an [ __ ] at times I'll
be real about that I mean he was my
father but you know there were times
where all right if I wanted something I
was either gonna have to work three
extra shifts at Subway during the week
or I was gonna have to figure out a way
to put all of this stuff to save up my
money or there's times where I had to
sell my Nintendo tapes just to try and
get something so yeah you start figuring
out ways early on
Macy's cards dude I used to go I used to
go around the neighborhood when I was
like 14 and rake yards that was my thing
I will go out and rake yards and I would
people would pay me $15 $10 for the
front 15 front and back and I will go
around and I probably do I don't know
eight or nine yards in a week and then
on days that I wasn't getting any hits
and nobody was really hidden I would
wait till it was late at night sometimes
I go around with leaves that I raped
just swing them [ __ ] into somebody's
yard and then wait a day $2.00 front 18
front him back there for ways to
innovate
I guess the seed was already there for
sure but yeah it's you you just have to
figure out ways to cut corners and
figure out ways to do more and that's
not something you can teach it's just
something that I feel like it's
instinctive right you know it's
something that you have to you have to
trust your instincts you have to trust
whatever is telling you to do a
particular thing or pulling you a
certain way even if it doesn't feel
right or even if other people are
telling you that's not the right move
that's not how you do it there ain't no
[ __ ] right way to do this [ __ ] man
no guy telling you there's no two people
at the top of comedy who did it the same
way right so you can't
this isn't sports it's not linear it's
not will you do good and you hit shots
you get rebounds and then you get
drafted and then you be good in the
league thank know that's not how it
works sometimes you have to have a good
digital following so that means more to
some people now and if you're not good
at social thing you have to figure out
another way to find your audience
because that's what Booker's are looking
for and that's what TV's looking forward
to looking for I already have an
audience which is unfortunate but that's
the reality of the business now your dad
had to have some influence because he
was in radio also and was like big and
like a Black Power movement and you've
you're you're we're in radio and you
clearly like your material has been
racially driven to a degree as well like
having that voice it's like there must
have been some sort of influence there
besides him just being a quote [ __ ]
yeah I think there was there's
definitely some innate influence you
know my father used to take me with him
on his speaking engagements so to some
degree it was kind of like traveling
with the comedian you know my dad did
radio he did but he wasn't like a DJ
good morning everyone I know W to be ill
was soulful sounds my dad was like
straight-up hardcore news and commentary
and my father figured out a way to make
sure that his words got across like I
don't not explain it but he was like a
great orator that's the word I'm looking
for he was a great orator and he would
have speaking engagements at churches
and stuff and it really ended up being
the internship the right word I guess
like it was it was definitely good for
me as a child to see my dad doing that
stuff because it definitely influenced
me what's weird is that I try my best to
like boom oh man I'm nothing like my
parents and
I'm on stage talking about race same
[ __ ] guy my church has a better bar
way do you know you've not just a racial
comedian I mean you've broken down a lot
of barriers and been influenced in a lot
of different ways but I you know that's
where the roots are though and I just
didn't want listeners to hear you beam
all my dad was an [ __ ] and just kind
of dismiss it but I mean he influenced
yeah oh yeah my dad was an embedded
reporter with the civil rights movement
he was in Vietnam as a reporter like my
dad did dope [ __ ] man there's just
sometimes my father didn't want to give
me no money for sneakers
hmm so I had to go rake yards you figure
out ways like you know you'd go buy a
camera from Circuit City and then return
it after you were done with the
innovation like no one teaches you that
that's why I get furious bro I get
furious when I meet young comics who go
oh no how you [ __ ] crazy now I was
returning cameras to Circuit City
tonight a 15-percent of stocking feet
they don't even have that now you could
do stuff by mail with Amazon so when a
guy tells me like when I see comics
online who have a tape of themselves
performing and this is a tape they're
using a shop themselves to other clubs
and it's a trash ass tape there's no
excuse for that there's no excuse for
bad audio and bad video mmm it's
unforgivable they shoot entire movies on
iPhones now so you're a lazy [ __ ] and
you get what you deserve and they you
could easily take five 600 bucks you can
take 300 bucks on the low end go buy a
camera from an electronics store use it
and then return it within the 14 day
return window and just say I didn't like
it they don't even that show any
questions and even if they do just go
ahead did work out old someone else gave
me one as a gift and I didn't need this
one they surprised me for
my anniversary the girlfriend surprised
me for our anniversary
whatever-whatever law you want to come
up with but there are so many ways to do
more god damn I wish I had the the
collaborative spirit that young comics
and youtubers that they have because the
thing that I think that a lot of
youtubers and instagramers have over
traditional stand-ups they have the
know-how to understand that we're
stronger together sorry to get all I
don't know [ __ ] political slogan on
you know wasn't on purpose but they
strengthen numbers there we go alright
there's strength in numbers so there's a
collaborative spirit between a lot of
digital comedians that traditional
stand-ups don't always have and at least
I didn't see it coming up is very much a
bunch of loners we're a bunch of loners
who show up to like you know it's like
how anacondas mate if that makes sense
I this is a horrible analogy but I've
already started it male anacondas like
they they show up just to [ __ ] once a
year and they have a big orgy [ __ ] fest
wicious all these [ __ ] anacondas and
a ball and a [ __ ] and whatever and
then they disperse that's what open mic
night is once a week a bunch of comics
comedy y'all crawl and roll around with
each other and everyone should try to
get stage time trying to get their
career pregnant and then you disperse
and I feel like
there's less of a hey man let's have a
joke meeting let's sit and powwow let's
make each other's jokes stronger like
stupid little things like that yeah and
that's why you see guys that work
together they have a room they start a
room together and things like that they
are they are better off if you find
someone that is as driven as you [ __ ]
team up with them
period you'll make each other better
you'll go further faster together and
comedy is such a loner sport and then we
got we had a lot of bad mentors too
especially in the south because more
often than not you're on the road and
you're opening for a guy it's not all
the guys on the road because I've pretty
much opened for every headliner that's
still working right now if they're still
here lining right now on the road in the
south in the Midwest
95% chance I know them and have worked
with them mm-hmm and I would say about
half of that allotment of guys come from
a different stand-up era so their
ideologies are different their approach
is different and you cannot do what
you're trying to do now approaching it
from an 80s and 90s style of career
building if you will those guys are
passed either wanting to learn digital
all right look I know [ __ ]
doing this man I still don't have a
Facebook page site [ __ ] you man like
that's cool but you cannot if you're a
new guy you can't copy that
that dude also had 20 years of building
to get to that point to where he can
just afford to tour on his name but if
you're just trying to start out and just
get your foot in the door you've got to
have a digital like you have no choice
man and I don't know I sound real ranty
today I'm not trying to but information
I just feel like newer comics have more
at their disposal and I think part of
why the Atlanta community has grown case
in point is because there is more
connectivity with comics starting their
own rooms independent comedy markets
that have good independent rooms birth
better comics because there's more
places to get on stage and to start a
room that's a very bold as thought to
just go you know what I like that's
straight-up outside the box because
running a room is hard it's hard to run
a room every week and still be a decent
comedian that's why so few comedians own
comedy clubs you would think we were own
comedy club but it's like the NBA half
the players don't want to be owners
because they don't want to figure that
[ __ ] out right right so I don't know man
I just feel like the more that I only
remember what the [ __ ] question was
but just the more collaborative people
are in the early stages of their career
the better off you'll be down the road
you know I have guys that I started with
that I wish I was a little more had been
a little more collaborative with when I
had the time and it just you're just
thinking inulin gotta get a TV critic go
to go to cheesy credit right go to get
on gotta get on Leno if I get on Leno
then I'm handed a sitcom wrong ya know
no more you clink collaborative like
with Sullivan and Sons it was like a TV
show with comedians and you guys would
like do a season and then go on a tour
together do a season and go before
that's all Steve Byrne it's still like a
collaborative that helped you
I agree but what I say did Steve burning
me me being cast on the show that was
all Steve burn after Last Comic Standing
Rhett studios weren't checking for me
and I was I got third place on Last
Comic Standing right I made it to the
second to last commercial break of the
season so I was on the entire season and
I was getting auditions here and there
but it was annoying Steve Byrne and
working with him and riding with him
here and there that Steve kept me in
mind for the project and he was the one
who got me the audition
that wasn't my agent or my manager that
was a relationship that I had with
someone and those things go very very
far and did The Daily Show come from a
relationship as well Daily Show was a
little bit more of AA / - okay here's
here's something like so when Sullivan's
son got canceled I started doing work
with ESPN supports nation hmm and just
doing sports video blocks and I was
doing sports video blogs on my own I was
like you know what I want I love talking
about sports and comedy and if I do
something often enough and it's funny
enough you keep putting it out on the
web eventually gains traction it could
take two months if you take two years
but you create a consistent funny web
content you can rise above the noise and
I started doing that and that that vlog
is what got me the opportunity to start
doing sports a nation I started doing
stuff with USA Today sports and like
just making all these weird comical
sports videos so when Trevor Noah was
announced to take over the daily show
and he started the producers start kind
of trolling the web and talking around
in circles you know we need black we
need political minded who you got we
need someone that can already you know
so for me everything that I was doing
with the sports stuff with the ESPN
ended up kind of being pre audition tape
for them to look at to see me on camera
being funny about something
and speaking about it with a level of
passion and comedy and information still
coming through so you know for me I feel
like that was more the producers putting
fillers out and things like that and
just go on from there it was it was a
little bit of that and then I also feel
like somebody probably put my name and I
don't want to say who on the podcast or
whatever but I feel like somebody
definitely was like hey make sure you
take a look at Roy mm-hm and once they
were pointed in my direction they went
in looked at the body of work and like
all right he can audition and you know I
just I had I had a guardian in second
time you ate a dick in 2007 auditioned
this was so fine I auditioned and
thought that yeah yeah walk in nobody
really laughs but nobody I don't see
nobody laughs the communications but
it's not uncommon to run your script and
someone not laugh they've seen this
performed nine times ninety thousand
times at this point so going to my [ __ ]
and um they go alright thanks Roy I walk
out the room and sitting in the waiting
room it's this guy Wyatt Cenac and so I
know why we've seen each other around LA
why it walks in and as I'm going to walk
off I realized I left my car keys in the
room so I have to sit and wait for why
it's audition to conclude so I can go
back and get my keys
the laughs I heard coming through that
wall and you're just sitting there and
you I'm just slumped in a chair I'm
defeated
cuz I'm like there's no way and I'm
hearing why I can hear his audition and
murder and and you hear it any like oh
that's how you do that line [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up that part of the script
because no one's teaching you out they
give you the script and see how much you
instinctly how much you know of instinct
on how to interpret this script and how
to make it funny where to if the
punctuation the pause is the comedic
moments that are in the script so I blew
the audition why cement rushes door
swings open and I come back in like
applause instantly stops yeah I love my
car keys I just smoke get my car keys
I'm not the black guy see ya later yeah
why I got the daily show cuz he [ __ ]
deserved it man he crushed that [ __ ]
from I don't know five six years so to
get a second opportunity yeah I was
alright I'm ready now
yeah and that's that's that's definitely
a blessing because you don't get you
don't get a chance to do a lot of stuff
twice in this business like you don't
get a chance to nail something again
it's you wait forever you get your shot
and then that's it see in five years
buddy when you got another idea you got
something else up your sleeve and the
funny thing is that like even now with
being on The Daily Show I don't know if
it's a road comic thing or just a
comedic thing but like I still don't
feel settled mm-hmm career-wise even
working ten hours a day at the Daily
Show or where I know it's great still
feel like I don't want to see you feel
like you could all go away but there is
part of that and so with the time I have
what the opportunities I have in my
hands I'm gonna do the best I can to
just do my best you know Sullivan & Son
got a third get cancelled after we'd
already been promised a fourth season
Wow it was a gentleman's handshake no
paperwork had been signed but you know a
new guy came into the network and
decided to cancel everything on the
network but Conan so that's just what it
is so you know things can go a lot of
different ways fast so I just feel like
is it's comics when we have an
opportunity to do something that's
impactful like if you have a one-hour
special then you need to [ __ ]
kick-ass it needs to be something that
really states who you are what you about
what your worth is and for me that's
always been the most important thing
with this career so when I got another
opportunity to be on The Daily Show and
any sketch they give me
I'm balls to the wall man yes I want
this to be funny and the thing with the
daily show - airing that [ __ ] man it's
like putting on a Yankees Jersey it is
there's something story with that and I
I need to honor the work that everybody
else did before me on the daily show and
I need to make sure that whoever comes
after me on the daily show still has
something that's well I'm not like
Trevor Noah had the best analogy said he
feels like he's been handed the keys to
his dad's Ferrari and he can't scratch
it you know and I understand that now I
don't want to be the one to mess up the
show yeah you're on the Yankees but yet
you're still not settled so like what is
you mentioned creating goals earlier in
this interview but like so what are
something what are some of your goals no
you still have to have goals you still
have to have
mile markers to set for yourself uh-huh
cuz if you don't you become complacent
so even with the daily show before the
daily show I had two pilots that I wrote
so now the goal becomes you know maybe
trying to sell those or figuring out a
way they just shoot a web series or
something I think scheduling-wise I
don't think a lot of what I can do make
sense right now because of my commitment
the time commitments of the show but I
feel like I can still try to executive
produce something and I've I've lost my
desire to star in anything interesting
like I love television but to me the
real creative control is behind the
camera it's with the pen in the pad and
I've become a little more obsessed with
what the story what story is being told
then how the stories being told so if I
had to choose right now if you gave me
an opportunity to star in a sitcom
versus creating and just executive
producing the sitcom I'd probably choose
the latter because there's also more
longevity behind the camera you know if
you go there the only way I compare it
is this whatever your favorite sitcom is
that guy canceled whenever it got
canceled just do exercise look at the
actors on the sitcom that got canceled
and pull up pull them up on IMDB like
literal quantitative data pull up their
IMDB page and look how much they worked
since that hit sitcom got cancelled
then I want you to pull up the writers
of that sitcom that got canceled and
pull up their IMDB and you tell me who's
had a longer career hmm the longevity is
in being behind the camera effort me
longevity greater sign stardom I'd be
blessed to just have a career where I
can just create dope content like I look
at what Donald Glover did with this TV
show Atlanta effects a goddamn man like
he's literally control-alt-delete it mmm
the sitcom format mm-hmm and to do
something that tells the story if I can
star in it fine if not I don't care I
feel like there's other ways to still
build my brand and sell tickets on the
road and at the end of the day that's
what this is all about it's all to sell
tickets Chris Rock Center everything I
do is to bring more people to my comedy
I'm [ __ ] up the quote it's still at
the end of the day stand-up you want to
be 55 years old with a gut and three
kids and still be able to do this [ __ ]
mmm-hmm the sooner or later Hollywood
had chewed me up and spit me out and
they'll tell me I'm too old or too fat
or too black you know whatever and at
that point you need to be able to still
go back out on the road and be a decent
comic or if you're a creator then
there's something more there you know I
look at what's happening with Ava
Duvernay
and ISA ray over at HBO creators Issa
Rae is a great [ __ ] example of self
star every [ __ ] comedian should just
read her bio and see where she's at just
every comedian should just see where
Issa Rae was in 2000
12 2011 okay versus now and if you
telling me you can't self start and do
this [ __ ] yourself you're a lazy [ __ ]
you lazy [ __ ] and you deserve whatever
your career is there's no excuses
there's literally no excuses for that
well you've been so generous with your
time I know you waking up early to do
this after filming two specials yeah I'm
sorry I sound like [ __ ]
and I'm sorry that there was is this
Christmas music they're playing I don't
know I don't know what the what the DJ
is but they clearly got them off
Craigslist there's a DJ at the W Hotel
in midtown atlanta is trash at 7 a.m. on
a Saturday it's a nice hotel but DJ is
trash well you know before we get out of
here you know is there anything else you
want the world to know know majus for
comedians of comedians are listening to
this challenge yourself if it's writing
a couple new jokes every month and B
every week that's well I'll tell you
something I [ __ ] some old comic tell
me man you know so you don't know
anything about this game kid I know that
I have I write five new minutes a day
every day I write five minutes now was I
in my head oh wow
even if two of those minutes are funny
that's still a new hour every month I'm
older down that man was full of [ __ ]
right but I think what he was trying to
tell me challenging me was you know to
write a little bit more you know and you
know for fans of comedy continue to
support it continue to go out to the
clubs live comedy all that good [ __ ]
because it helps well Roy Wood jr. thank
you for being on hot breath man my
pleasure
hope my breath wasn't too hot are you
good and if you want people to know
where they can keep up with you you can
definitely
my name is Roy Wood jr. Google me no ass
on my name oh all right
Roy Wood jr. thank you
[Music]
[Music]